la revanche est fêté son 20e
anniversaire ce dimanche 17 juin 151
coureurs ont participé à cette édition
2010 8 sur la colline d'elancourt cinq
fois plus que lors de la première
édition imaginé en 1998 par les
organisateurs bah c'est une tradition
c'est c'est l'histoire de saint quentin
en yvelines l'histoire de cette colline
ce site
il était à l'abandon et accueil vraiment
nous notre club qui utilise aussi de
akon d'elancourt et quand on pense qu'on
a il va y avoir les jeux olympiques je
pense que on a mis une petite pierre à
l'édifice pour que je sois ici quoi
depuis 20 ans le parcours a peu évolué
pour cette édition 2010 8 un tracé
technique a été dessiné sur le point
culminant de l'île de france avec ses
231 m honte la grosse but qui fait très
mal aux jambes
et maintenant ça devient de plus en plus
dur
voilà parce qu'elle est très raide et il
ya il n'y a pas du tout du tout 2
on peut on peut pas du tout
récupérer c'est hyper dur c'est
extrêmement extrêmement dur il faut
trouver un bon rythme car dirait qu'une
fois qu'on est on est partis qu'on a
passé le sommet quand la côte arguin on
est déjà chaud et ça ça va déjà mieux
les au bout de l'effort c'est geoffroy
le turc qui remporte cette 20e édition
pour sa première participation à
l'épreuve derrière moi il y avait des
deux concurrents et j'ai décidé
d'attaquer dans une bosse directement
des premiers tours pour pour être
tranquille après au final ça s'est super
bien passé j'ai creusé l'écart au fil
des tours et et puis voilà je finis en
tête et c'est cool cette épreuve a
également permis comme chaque année de
récolter des dons pour les orphelins des
sapeurs pompiers de france
au total 3000 auront été reversés à
l'association
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour une
21e édition